we know in reality it's nothing but love
between all the Avengers and at this
point well it's pretty hard to imagine
anyone else as Thor Iron Man Captain
America but for the men of Marvel Mickey
were actually almost cast differently I
wasn't on the first kind of a batch of
guys up for this role with Marvel I feel
plenty of pressure constantly thank you
for that question I can do this all day
this particular week I haven't worn many
but this is uh this is this is quite
comfortable I forget it's there love the
time the first half-hour of being in the
Iron Man suit is like the coolest
Halloween you've ever had
I am Iron Man do I have any of the same
qualities as Peter quill or star-lord
yeah I suppose I mean we're both
devilishly handsome we look a lot alike
could you imagine
star-lord played by Eddie Redmayne John
Krasinski as Captain America Joseph
gordon-levitt was one of the final two
but Paul Rudd one out for ant-man and
Charlie Hunnam auditioned to be Thor but
he wasn't the only one was that crazy
bill that your brother was one of the
leading candidates it was funny busted
came all the way over here from
Australia and ended up you know battling
against each other et has been on set
with the men of Marvel from the very
beginning at the time all of them were
pretty freaked out to take on their
superhero roles hopefully it'll work out
if it doesn't it'll totally be my fault
I hope I'm the right guy at the right
time I've never been so scrutinized
before I even started shooting a movie
and you know they definitely gotta look
the part so not easy but not gonna lie
we really appreciate the hard work
I haven't had beer basically in the year
2013 if you know how much beer I drink
before you'd know how hard it is for me
to not drink beer and falling down a bit
I'm almost 30 and I really think when
you hit that 300 things just start
staying a little bit longer than they
used to stay I was less concerned about
Blake you know whether my boss it was as
big as his boss so that's this does your
friend it's great by the way having a
reason to have to stay in shape is
really really good it forces you to stay
on the treadmill what did you do to get
jacked like that I mean you're big
you're big boy I loved working out in
the media
yeah hi chicken I hide eggs
[Music]
[Applause]